بهذه اليمين يبدا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان رسميا ولايته الرئاسيه الجديده
تضمنت مراسم التنصيب ايضا زياره ضريح مؤسس
الجمهوريه مصطفى كمالاتورك ومع هذه
المراسم تدخل تركيا
لجمهوريتها بعد ان تخلصت من تبعات السباق
الانتخابي وما رافقه من تجاذبات سياسيه
داخليه
عشرات المسؤولين الدوليين شاركوا في حفل
تنصيب الرئيس التركي وفي كلمته امام الحفل
حدد اردوغان ملامح الفتره المقبله
سنحقق الرؤيه التي وعدنا بها ناخبين لنقل
تركيا الى قرن جديد في السنوات الخمس
المقبله سنحرر ديمقراطيتنا من الدستور
الحالي الذي هو نتاج انقلاب ونعززها
بدستور تحرري ومدني وشامل سنواصل تنميه
بلدنا من خلال الاستثمار والتوظيف
والانتاج والصادرات وتحقيق فائض مالي
[تصفيق]
ولتحقيق هذه الاهداف اختار اردوغان في
تشكيلته الحكوميه الجديده اسماء بارزه اذ
سلم حقيبه الخارجيه الى هاكان فيدان الذي
كان يراس جهاز المخابرات التركيه كما عين
علي وزيرا للداخليه ويشار جولار وزيرا
للدفاع ومحمد شمشك وزيرا للخزانه والماليه
والبرسلان بيركتار وزيرا للطاقه والموارد
الطبيعيه تحديات عده ستكون في انتظار
الحكومه الجديده
امام الحكومه التركيه في الفتره المقبله
تحديات عده من الاقتصاد الى الامر وصولا
الى تطورات في السياسه الخارجيه مما لا
تخضعوا لسيطره تركيا كلمه السر ستكون في
تحديد الاولويات والرؤيه التي سيعمل من
خلالها الرئيس خصوصا وان مفتاح الاستقرار
الداخلي هو الاقتصاد والخارجي هو الامن
خفت في الشارع حده الاستقطاب السياسي الذي
رافق السباق الانتخابي نصب الرئيس وشكل
حكومته وباتت الانظار تتجه الان الى مدى
كفاءه الحكومه الجديده في مواجهه التحديات
امام تركيا
المعتز بالله حسن الجزيره انقره